this Justin billion-dollar franchise
launch Trump's Best Picture nomination
Wow let's take a little box office bow
thank you very much if a film crew is a
tribe the cinematographer is the shaman
battling the elements working with light
and shadow to convey that the effort is
as tall as the rest of us by framing out
the Apple boxes he so often is standing
or crafting an elegant master that
simultaneously conveys story character
and height equality yet the true
abilities of a cinematographer are often
tested most when an aging star whose
years make that decades of wanton
self-abuse leaves his face looking like
a lunar landing surface excuse me
Robbins you talking about me at you he's
talked about you well then in Roberts
and my defense it was not decades of
knob use maybe more like a decade yes
two and a half years times ten or a
quarter century right here are the
nominees for achievement in
cinematography Anna Karenina Seamus
McGarvey Django Unchained Robert
Richardson lifepod Bobby L Moran
Lincoln Janusz Kaminski Skyfall
Roger Deacon and the Oscar goes to
Claudia Miranda Life of Pi
this is the first Academy Award
Oh Miranda oh gee Wow ah
this movie was uh was quite a beast to
make uh we did it and the thing would I
had was so much which Sony great this
that everyone just was really totally
there and supportive I mean I was really
into you know Aang in the beautiful
world that week it was like one
challenge when you're a cinematographer
and there's like one thing they just
kind of we just have your eyes and just
kind of go up and help it up and up and
I mean you just kind of reach this thing
they get really excited there's exciting
scenes for me that I love like the
candles and the things we did there was
nuts
oh Jesus but it was really great and I
I'd like to thank everyone that made
this thing totally possible the Academy
the Fox and oh my god I can't speak cuz
I know and wrap up now of a whole thing
yeah I'd like to thank my wife my
daughter is up there and both everyone
thank you so much